[Musique]
marie-hélène marque dit sur i libel
bonjour l bonjour alors d'accord
marie-hélène match où il y à l'oni 58
ans et puis ou km analystes combat
ouvrit à noter présent chaque élection
interne et ghislaine jeannot gabriel
jean marie et puis actuellement c'est au
caa les putschistes et aux galets parce
que w9 en outaouais mi6 gabriel jean
marie putsch manqué et bien mon cas
conduit l'islande 6 a raconté brad
manning passion camatchy viable et
jean-marie hyper a montré dans l'islam
ok dany problème ça tout shiso calais
parce que ça zot quatre ados élections
tard eh bien il faut que et y travailler
chômeurs retraités gène ikke à
souffraient en lui ils forment les camps
de travail est toujours présent et c'est
ça nous les faits nous les à travers les
élections présente en lice combat
ouvrier pour permettre que les camps de
travail est ni représentants c'est pour
ça que nous caler à toutes les fonctions
disait exactement il veut que ces
travailleurs tout plat puisque noidans
souffrance la preuve en est depuis le 7
décembre même avant le 5 décembre
tout mon en lutte tout mon handident en
détresse pour quelles raisons c'est
parce que société à calais mal alors
lieu au cap à l'est où l'audi dit
l'agent qu'à moitié
fort-de-france la 114e dit ça eh bien
c'est la pensée c'est que fort le fond
c'est pas travailler c'est pas chômé et
ses parents retraités qu'imiter la ville
et à une situation d'endettement
cueillis il faut que l'état
on parle de responsabilité l'ammoniaque
attendu comme odile et à l'agent metella
genre qualité l'argent manque a vu les
vidéos que c'est pas travailler c'est
parfois traités c'est pas chaud mais
c'est pas les jeunes qui endetté la
ville fort de france alors c'est l'état
qui avait de la ville voleurs en
conséquent si l'état café ça qu'il faut
pour permettre les les communes ni les
moyens plus haut fonctionner et bien là
les communes qu'elle fonctionnait
américain fonctionner mais seulement des
mots plutôt que c'est pas travailler
c'est pas chaud mais c'est pas les
retraités c'est pas les jeunes qui ont
du talent avec votre fils mais à part
mais à qui l'a pas responsable à l'eau
celle d'avocat lui répéter aussi à la
jeunesse et palais travail et n'ont même
aucun effet open c'est celle responsable
d'une île bol c'est l'état puisse
capucci c'est une dotation qui diminue
qui commettait ses gonds mines la
difficulté est bien fort combien elle
est assise en face au et puis d'ivoire
la situation commune en ville
d'accord mais situation les travailler
mais situation les chaumes situations
les gènes qui sont pas dit nous c'est ça
est ce parce que là où aux cadeaux que
vu la ion est endetté willow cartonne
depuis des années honnêtement tu as
montré même acabit ne voudrait peut-être
c'est pas la jeunesse c'est pas les
chauvins c'est pas les retraités s'est
passé mon antique à travail là les
travailleurs puisque nous nous calons
représenter le camp des travailleurs le
compte d exploiter c'est paillot qui
mettait quel que soit qu'il avait le
fond le franc suisse que l'ensemble des
communes ont été unis problème c'est pas
si c'est par catégorie de mandalas qui
fait que ville endettée l'état capon
responsabilités vis-à-vis de toutes ces
problématiques posées quoi il commet
yucca au cas où
car fait pourtant demi sa joie parce que
ni travaillait et ni retraités aller
chaque 10 qui ni comment et où quand
comment différencier mais sa joie comme
le cac tonnes ni sa joie est bien beau
cadeau que c'est celle lice c'est celle
du ski cap à l'est dit quand les
travailler c'est sale c'est la liste de
combat ouvrier c'est nous seuls qui
nuançaient luchini disco de la capa les
deux situations que nous la vivons dit
donne un exemple donc à viry prix bas
depuis le 7 février même avance à
l'hôpital
les collèges les écoles mais tout mis en
mouvement pucci parce qu'ayant situation
qui pas bon ipa ben maintenant la
conscience conscience peut placer ça
nous les éveiller en jour conscience la
caf lui loge plus grand et que hook est
vrai qu'une keynote disco handident
population parce que le capitalisme
cadetg oui nous et que nous peut pas
aller ni nouveau ni des nous nous tenons
handidanse elle engone à gensac nous pas
ça a déplacé qu'on nous passe a failli
et c'est la pauvreté qui kakou guikahué
les nommer et inuh cas les situations
mac de marie et les natures dites sur
elie magail version shy émission tabou
tu aimé ma cadeaux messi et que manca
passe et que conscience ce travail et
qu'elle permette que la liste combat
ouvrier
cailleux que toujours en pantalon ce que
tu veux que mutek exactement vers les
ouvertures nécessaires pour que les cas
des travailleurs puissent plus se
trouver en place à doha avait remplaça
d'or de communes a manqué mais aussi en
taille il mesure a été réalisée par
adele qui kelly mais c'est un chèque
[Musique]